My name is Michael's whirling. I'm the
proud owner of KSCO news talk AM 1080
and FM 104.1 in Santa Cruz, California.
A place where there are more characters
per square inch than anywhere on the
planet. It was a lifelong dream for me
to own this station from the time I was
a high school kid.
And in 1991,
25 years ago,
I was able to realize that lifelong
dream. But be careful what you wish for
because even though I was so passionate
about running a radio station that
serves the community,
we did a very good job of serving the
community, but guess what? It didn't pay
financially. It was almost impossible to
sell enough advertising to pay what it
cost to run a radio operation like this.
And that's why you won't find a talk
radio station anywhere in the country or
probably in the world that's anything
like KSCO. I'm going to share with you
the secret of our success and longevity.
For the last 25 years, we have been able
to do
almost the impossible.
And that is because I joined a company
called Youngevity, founded by Dr. Joel
Wallach, an absolutely amazing person.
I'm very proud to present the following
video presentation
that has just blown me away.
Dr. Wallach has a message that everybody
needs to see, and I want to share it
with you starting right now. This is
about your health and longevity.
Hello, I'm Dr. Joel Wallach, and we're
here to talk about health and longevity
today.
And the thing that makes my view
different is that I have a degree in
agriculture. I'm a veterinarian. I wrote
the first paper on a mass die-off from
pollution in America 1961.
I am a comparative pathologist and I've
done 20,000 autopsies, 17,000 of them
changed or 454 species of animals and
3,000 humans. This is for the Center for
the Biology of Natural Systems
a composite of Washington University St.
Louis, the St. Louis Zoo and the Shaw's
Botanical Gardens.
And I also have a degree post-doctoral
fellowship in comparative pathology
which is the equivalent of a PhD in
comparative pathology.
And I'm a primary care physician I since
1982 I've been licensed as a primary
care physician and naturopathic
physician
from
Oregon I'm licensed in Oregon and I'm
also licensed in California again as a
primary care physician.
And of course this gives me a different
view on things. What you're going to see
here in this presentation is why we're
in trouble. Why our children are dying
before we do. They're they're going to
be the first generation Americans who do
not live as long as their parents.
Why our food is depleted of of nutrients
has nothing to do
with pollution.
And we have a real problem here. And
what you're going to find is we're going
to give you solutions and we can all win
this game together
but everybody's going to have to be
obsessive about making these things
happen. So here we go.
And of course
you're seeing here some of the various
awards I've won so it gives me a little
credibility.
And I graduated agricultural school at
the University of Missouri. I graduated
veterinary school at the University of
Missouri and before graduating
veterinary school I actually started
taking courses in pathology and this is
me getting an award at the United
Nations for natural medicine lifetime
achievement award for natural medicine
and philanthropy.
And the ambassador on
the right side of your picture is this
wonderful lady she's the ambassador from
Nepal and the gentleman on your left is
the ambassador from Dubai the UAE the
United Arab Emirates. This is off the
stage after receiving award. This is
kind of the red carpet thing. And this
is me in 19, well, this is me in 2011
getting the Klaus Schwarz award for
trace mineral research in the prevention
reversal of birth defects. And most of
you've heard or read the audiocassette
tape the CD or the
book Dead Doctors Don't Lie. Uh the CD
is in 12 different languages all over
the world and it's sold over 300 million
copies. We're very very proud of that.
Obviously somebody's interested in the
message. Now, this is a word cloud and
it's just going to be a brief
introduction to some of the concepts
we're talking about before we get into
the details so you know where we're
going. I want you to look in the upper
right-hand corner and you'll notice it
says obesity. The prevailing theory for
100 years on obesity has been obesity is
caused by eating too much and lack of
exercise. Well, we followed that theory
for 100 years and what did we get? We're
the number one obese nation in the
world.
It's a failed theory. Basically, being
overweight and obese is really due to a
deficiency of a certain group of
nutrients and if any one of them are
missing, you're going to start gaining
some weight. There's several of those
nutrients in that group. If you're
missing them, you're going to weigh 400,
600, 800 lbs.
And so,
obesity can be gotten rid of very
quickly but you have to supplement with
these nutrients and then the cravings,
the munchies, the binge eating
goes away very simply. You can lose a
half pound to two pounds a day and we'll
talk more about that in detail in a
moment. The red rectangle uh just below
obesity has the word Alzheimer's in it.
Alzheimer's disease is certainly not
caused by eating aluminum or being in
contact with aluminum deodorant. We're
looking at a disease that's a
physician-caused disease. Alzheimer's
disease is a physician-caused disease.
Not caused by aluminum, absolutely not
genetic. It's a simple nutritional
deficiency disease driven by doctors
telling people to do things, telling
their patients to give up cholesterol
and saturated fat. It's a cholesterol
deficiency. We'll talk more about this
in a moment. Then there's cardiovascular
disease. This is probably one of the
biggest hoaxes because it's proactive.
It's in other words, it was consciously
done
to sell another product. And this is
where Procter & Gamble to make a long
story short, ultimately bought the
patents
for a substance that was used as a
submarine diesel engine lubricant, a
smokeless lubricant originally. And
after the war, they didn't need it as a
submarine diesel engine lubricant
anymore. And so Procter & Gamble wound
up with it and they were going to sell
it as soap and they couldn't sell it as
soap because people were making their
own soap. And they decided to use it as
a shortening for cooking, but they had
to demonize what grandma had been using
for centuries and that is lard, butter,
cream, and eggs for cooking. And what
they did, again to make a long story
short, through Ancel Keys who was on the
board of Procter & Gamble and also on
the board of the American Heart
Association, he brokered a deal in which
the Procter & Gamble gave a $1.7 million
grant to the American Heart Association
in in exchange for an endorsement of
this diesel lubricant as a replacement
for lard, butter, cream, and
demonization of cholesterol and
saturated fat. Also, they came up with
the idea of the Mediterranean diet to
sort of make it more sexy to give those
things up. Mediterranean diet and it's
turned out that these are all false
things. We'll talk about that more in a
minute detail. But basically, congestive
heart failure, one of the more common
causes of heart disease in adults all
over the industrialized world, is due to
a deficiency of a single vitamin. We've
known that for 300 years. It was
proposed by Japanese naval surgeon 300
years ago. Cardiomyopathy heart disease,
I'm very familiar with that. It's a
deficiency of a single mineral.
And you see this
resulting in sudden deaths in athletes
or sudden deaths in people who do hard
physical work. I've actually done 1,700
autopsies on kids under the age of 10
that have died of this one in Keshan
province, China. It's a deficiency of a
single mineral. It has nothing to do
with cholesterol or saturated fat.
Then there's coronary artery disease.
That has nothing to do with saturated
fat or cholesterol.
Coronary artery disease, and I said this
in 1971 after doing 20,000 autopsies on
the big NIH project with the Center for
the Center of Disease Control and also
for the Center of the Biological
Systems. And it's one of those things
where this was a
joint project between Washington
University in St. Louis, the St. Louis
Zoo and the Botanical Garden shows
Botanical Gardens, and Marlon Perkins.
Okay, Barry Commoner, those two guys put
this together and brought me back from
Africa where I was doing research and
conservation work with the white rhino
and the African elephant. Came back for
2 years after that project and began to
do these autopsies, 17,000 and change of
over
um let's see, 454 species of animals and
3,000 humans.
And the 1,200 page book that came out of
that is in the Smithsonian Institute.
And the bottom line of this finding of
this 10-year project was that every
animal and every human being who dies of
what we'd call natural causes dies of a
nutritional deficiency disease, not
pollution, and certainly not genetics.
So, it was kind of
um surprised everybody, but that's what
the study showed and everybody agreed
with the research.
And so
coronary artery disease again is not
caused by cholesterol or saturated fat.
It's actually caused by inflammation,
which was said in that book, which is in
the Smithsonian Institute.
And um it's caused by inflammation,
caused by eating inflammatory foods,
fried foods, processed meats, oils, yes,
oils, and gluten, wheat, rye, barley,
and oats.
And then there's coronary thrombosis.
One of my nine um lawsuits against the
FDA in federal court, and we won the
ability to say that coronary thrombosis
is not caused by cholesterol and
saturated fat, but is caused by actually
a deficiency of omega-3 essential fatty
acids
and are a ratio problem between
omega-3s, sixes, and nines.
Then you jump over to arthritis in the
lower left-hand corner, and arthritis in
fact is
a simply a multi-mineral and
multi-vitamin deficiency disease.
Rheumatoid arthritis has a secondary
infection with Mycoplasma, a bug that's
easily killed in a couple of weeks with
an antibiotic called minocycline, a
member of the tetracycline family. Then
you go straight up from arthritis in
this word cloud to diabetes.
And diabetes has nothing to do with
genetics. It's not a genetically
transmitted disease. Type 2 diabetes,
which makes up 90% of the diabetic
population, is in fact due to
a simple deficiency of a single mineral.
We've known that for almost 80 years
now. And of course, this allows us to
prevent and support the body's ability
to heal itself when you have type 2
diabetes. It's one of those little
miracles because
uh an example would be if uh you have
iron deficiency anemia, instead of
wanting to just give you an iron
supplement to solve the problem, medical
doctors want to do a bone marrow
transplant. And that's why we have such
complicated procedures and treatments
for diabetes when it's really a very
simple mineral deficiency disease.
And of course, in the beginning of time,
when human beings began to record things
and tell stories
into their families to get messages
passed down, they believed that diseases
were caused by evil spirits or things up
in the universe that they had no control
over.
And they knew there was infectious
disease. They didn't know the word
infection, but they knew they were
transmitted and they were very dangerous
diseases. They put writings on cave
walls. These cave walls and the cave art
they had pictures of shamans treating
people with infections and wounds.
And then of course, astrology is where
they believed this and we're talking
about physicians now, as well as the
patients, believed that um people would
get sick because they angered gods up in
the planets. And if they would sacrifice
either animals or uh even their
neighbors to these gods, they would be
appeased and would look kindly upon them
and let them survive through epidemics
and plagues or maybe prevent them from
getting disease or
um allow them to have healthy children.
And in more recent times, maybe in the
last 500 years,
um medical doctors got rid of their
competition by going to churches and
telling them that Grandma Ruthie was
healing people with her herbs and it was
really God's job to heal people and not
this witch.
And the church would send out
Inquisition committees to torture these
poor grandmothers into confessing that
they were a witch and then they would
burn them at the stake. And so the
churches were involved in helping
eliminate the competition for doctors.
Doctors originally believed um in the
last thousand years that diseases were
caused by an imbalance of different
fluids in the body, the humors they
called them. Imbalance of the humors.
And there was blood
and phlegm and urine and yellow bile and
black bile. And the way that they would
balance them back was to use
bloodletting. They put leeches on you,
suck blood out, or they would just cut
veins on the surface and allow a certain
amount of blood to drain out. And of
course physicians killed our first
president George Washington by
bloodletting him when he had a
respiratory infection. The first guy to
really look at nutritional deficiencies
in western world was a guy by the name
of Schussler. And he was a hospitalist
in in German hospitals and when engine
and patients would die after months or
longer in hospitals, he'd cremate the
bodies and analyze the minerals in their
ashes. And then he would actually
compare and relate the different mineral
levels in these bodies in the ashes with
their symptoms. And when people come in
with those same symptoms, he would give
them those minerals and he'd able to
cure many many people. And these became
known these minerals became known as
Schussler's cell salts. We're talking
about magnesium and phosphorus, sodium,
sulfur, silica, calcium, phosphorus, I
said
iron,
and potass-
All of these things were given and
people would get cured. So Schussler's
one of the first ones to point to
mineral deficiencies as possible causes
of certain diseases.
The FDA
moved from the seven food group pyramid
to the plate.
Now, their mantra has been to the
general public is just eat well, you get
everything you need. Eat plenty of uh,
dark fruits and vegetables to get
antioxidants and also eat the four food
groups. You're going to get everything
you need. Don't supplement, you could
overdose. And this has been a terrible,
terrible, terrible uh, event in
humanities development because as you
will see in a moment, you cannot get
everything you need just by eating
uh, foods of different colors and eating
well. Pharmaceuticals got started with
um, patent medicines, of course. We're
talking about uh, Professor Smith's or
Dr. Frank's uh, liver tonic which was
usually um, whiskey uh, that they had
home brewed. And one of the first ones
uh, here in America was a fellow with
the a German fellow by the name of a
Bayer. Actually uh, saw people's uh,
relieving their pain and their suffering
by chewing on white willow bark and he
made an alcohol extract of it, a
tincture if you will, and dried up the
and got a powder, made a pill out of it
and called it Bayer aspirin, was able to
relieve pain. That was one of the first
over-the-counter, truly what we'd call
an over-the-counter drug today.
Coca-Cola was also one of the first
pharmaceuticals. It was actually cocaine
to begin with again with. It was a
cocaine in liquid form, Coca-Cola.
And when it became necessary to pull the
cocaine out of it because it would
became a prescription item,
what we have here is they it would put
caffeine from coffee into the Coca-Cola
and they carbonated it and made it
something that everybody could drink in
the uh, little little uh, drugstores.
Before there was um,
Prozac
for depression,
medical doctors would write
prescriptions for cigarettes for
depression.
And when it became known that uh,
smoking tobacco or chewing tobacco
increased the risk of um, lung cancer
and mouth cancer and oral cancer and so
forth,
um, everybody sued the uh, tobacco
companies and the medical doctors got to
walk. Um, they were writing
prescriptions for 30, 40 years for
tobacco. They were the ones who were
intimately involved in causing lung
cancer, but nobody ever sued a doctor
for that because everybody went to the
deep pockets of the pharmaceutical
companies uh, which were at that time
the tobacco companies. Hospitals
overcharge people by as much as a
thousand percent
in modern times. 85% of all personal
bankruptcies are due to medical bills.
85% of all personal bankruptcies are due
to medical bills. It's a very very scary
prospect when you think about it. And
most of the debt in America and other
industrialized nations comes from
medical bills. People think they're
getting free medical care but they're
paying $6 a gallon gasoline in taxes to
pay for the free medical care. So it's
not really free. But it buys a lot of
votes to say you're going to give free
medical care to people if you vote for
me, right?
And the reason why this goes on is most
people don't go through their statements
that come in from the insurance
companies. When the statements come they
just look at the insurance statement
they throw it in the drawer without
opening it. And so nobody noticed that
um
hospitals are charging insurance
companies $500 for a single rubber glove
and so on.
And they continue to get away with it.
The number of Americans using five or
more drugs nearly doubles, okay? 59% of
American adults are on prescription
drugs. 59%. This is very very scary.
This is legal drug dealing is what it
amounts to. And of course most
prescription drugs with the exception of
antibiotics do not cure anything.
The exception of antibiotics which do
cure infections
things like bacterial meningitis,
bacterial pneumonia, abscesses,
bacterial intestinal infections and so
forth.
Um
but other than antibiotics there's not a
single drug that cures anything. They
all treat symptoms. They all relieve
symptoms. Some of them do a very good
job. Some of them have terrible side
effects including death. Death rates
rising for middle age white Americans.
Okay, this just came out. You see
November 2015
the death rates were rising for middle
age white Americans while declining for
other wealthy countries and among other
races and ethnic groups. The rise
appears to be driven by suicide, drugs
and alcohol abuse but but
when you look at these people who are
committing suicide and who are abusing
alcohol and drugs, these are ones who
have 6 8 10 12 15 terrible diseases,
degenerative diseases, chronic diseases,
making their lives miserable, and none
of the drugs are taking are helping
them. They're driven to look for
something that's going to give them
relief. Here's one guy who kind of
overdid it and he started billing for
one patient $5 a month for drug therapy
for cancer they didn't have. Well, he
got his hand caught in the cookie jar,
was put in jail for 175 years. In fact,
many many many more doctors should be
put on trial for the same
problems.
When doctors don't know what you have,
when they don't know what you have as
far as a disease, they say you have an
autoimmune disease, your body's
attacking itself. That way it takes the
responsibility away from them.
Gosh, instead of saying I I really don't
know, I have to do a little bit of
research to find out. In the meantime,
I'm going to give you this drug to give
you some relief. They never do. They
say, "Oh, you have an autoimmune
disease, your body's attacking itself.
Not much I can do for you." Or you have
a genetic disease. You're you just have
bad genes, there's not much I can do for
you.
Okay, it's not my fault. Well, let's
have a look.
CAT scans are linked to cancer cuz they
have as much as 500 chest x-rays worth
of radiation for one CAT scan. Even the
government says use them limit, you
know, on a limited basis. In In fact,
most of the time you shouldn't even use
a CAT scan. Harvard Medical School said
that 20 years ago, don't use CAT scans.
Okay, because of the radiation dangers.
They're linked to breast cancer and and
other forms of death. The mammogram is
not a prevention. Repeat that,
mammograms are not prevention. They also
have as much as 500 chest x-rays worth
of radiation one mammogram.
Why would you do that? Well, I've been
going to the same OBGYN for 25 years. I
really respect him and he said I really
should get a mammogram, so I did.
Women should get three and four
different um opinions before they make
choices like this.
And there's other options. Uh a high
resolution ultrasound would give you the
same information without the radiation.
Of course, an ultrasound the doctor
might only make 50 bucks, where in a a
mammogram he might make 1,200. Now this
story in the Japanese newspapers
kind of gives you the the idea what's
happening here with medical care in all
industrialized nations. If you notice
um medical care expenses in Japan have
increased from 2 trillion yen in 1970 as
2 trillion yen 20 year in 1970 to 37
trillion yen a year in 2009
and in 2014 it was actually 40 trillion
yen for 1 year 2014.
Well, you want to note that Japanese tax
revenues in 2013 totaled from all tax
revenues the country was 42.3 trillion.
So the doctors were paid 40 trillion of
that, only 2.3 trillion was left over to
do the business of the government. Now
you see why governments are going
bankrupt. All governments in the
industrialized world are going bankrupt
because of the cost of inefficient,
dangerous, and ineffective medical care.
Genetics is another failed theory of the
20th and 21st century. There's not a
single disease that's transmitted
genetically. There's not a single
disease
that is um transmitted genetically as
birth defects. All birth defects are
caused by nutritional deficiency of the
embryo. The concept of animals passing
on information whether you're an oak
tree or a fish or a human being or a
hummingbird or crocodile goes back to
the days of Charles Darwin. People had
noticed these things, but Charles Darwin
was the first one to write it down and
uh his cousin Francis Galton um really
enjoyed what Darwin was saying uh in his
book on the origin of species and began
a little sort of pseudo science called
eugenics.
And uh this started the entire world in
a race for gathering up territory cuz
everybody wanted to be the master race.
Remember this sort of stuff went on in
the 1800s, but uh Hitler picked it up in
the 1930s before the uh Second World War
and took eugenics to a horrible horrible
level uh in which oh I don't know the
Nazis killed over 40 million people who
they thought weren't worthy of living.
Kind of like um sel- uh selection
in farm animals. If you have one that
doesn't meet your criteria for
production or our standards of looks,
you eat them. Okay? And so, he was
killing people who didn't meet his
standards of the perfect
generation. Gregor Mendel, priest, was
the first one to talk about
things like um recessive and dominance.
He understood that in hybrids. He was he
was a priest, and he found out all this
information by studying pea plants and
how they uh worked when you began to
hybridize different types of pea plants.
Very, very smart guy.
1800s, Louis Pasteur invented the germ
theory, and he was a wine chemist, and
he invented pasteurization. He would
heat wine, prevent it from going to
vinegar. And he knew that fermentation
then was a biological process.
And
uh he also knew uh once he looked
through the first microscope, which was
invented by a Dutch eyeglasses maker Van
Leeuwenhoek,
he could see yeast actually growing in
fermenting wine and beer. And so, he
knew it's a biological process. He
heated it and stopped the process, so it
didn't go to vinegar.
Doctors still at the time believed that
the um fermentation process was a
chemical process, and as a result, when
you heated it, it actually uh went
faster, sometimes explosively. 1961, I
was able to find as a graduate student I
had graduated ag school and halfway
through veterinary school,
and taking graduate courses in
pathology, found the first mass die-off
in America from pollution,
uh did the research, uh found out how
how it happened exactly, uh tracked all
the chemistries, got it published. It
was my first publication. I gave a copy
to Marlin Perkins, and this is how he
was interested in me doing the autopsies
in his project for the Center for the
Biology of Natural Systems. Again, the
founding members were the University uh
Washington University of St. Louis, St.
Louis Zoological Garden, St. Louis Zoo,
and Shaw's Botanical Gardens. Barry
Commoner,
okay? Uh really a very, very smart
fellow when it came to biology, and
Marlin Perkins was one of my mentors.
and uh he remembered that paper I had
given him on the first mass die-off from
pollution.
And so I was in Africa working in the
white rhino conservation project in the
African elevation. And he sent me a
letter and invited me back to
work on this project with the Center for
the Biology of Natural Systems, be the
pathologist on the project. Because I
had given him this paper on pollution,
and they believed that pollution was a a
basic root cause of um
uh of diseases of natural causes. And
they wanted me to do autopsies on zoo
animals that lived in big zoos in the
big cities in the United States.
And they wanted to use the zoo animals
in these big zoos in the United States
as the canary in the mine, like the old
Welsh coal miners would take um canaries
down in the mine, and if gases would
leak into the mine, the canaries were
more sensitive than men, and they would
drop off the perch and die long before
the men were in danger, and they could
get out safely. And they felt that with
big zoos having 400, 500, 600 species of
animals, that um they could get
information before we actually got hurt.
And they actually froze bodies and sent
them to me from zoos all over North
America, Canada, United States, and
Mexico for this project. This is the
book that came out of it. This book,
Disease of Exotic Animals, 1,200 pages,
covers 20,000 autopsies, 10 million
chemistries, and is in the
Smithsonian Institute as a national
treasure. I'm very, very proud of that
work. All birth defects are caused by
nutritional deficiencies during the
development of the embryo. The embryo's
gone down essentially an assembly line.
If anything's missing that's required
for the production of cells or tissues
or organs, there's something missing at
that appropriate time during the first
trimester of pregnancy, guess what?
You're going to get a defect cuz
something's going to be missing. By the
time 1910, 1920 came along, we knew the
chemical analyses, we knew the
biochemistry
of genes and DNA and RNA, but nobody
really knew the physical structure, and
so it was kind of delaying genetic
engineering cuz nobody knew the physical
structure.
Well, in 1953, these two young fellows
here,
um James Watson from the United States
and Francis Crick from England proposed
a double helix. And it took nine years
when when all the way until 1962 before
the general science community agreed
with them and they got the Nobel Prize
for it. That time, James Watson was
named the director of the Cold Springs
genetic research laboratory for the
federal government in New York in
Manhattan Island.
In between 2003 and 2011, the human
genome was mapped out. We knew every
gene that's found in the human body.
And 850 biotech companies were formed
and spent trillions and trillions and
trillions of dollars
looking for screening tests that would
alert us early on that a child, say 2
years old, when they've when they're 48
they're going to get Parkinson's disease
or when they're 52 they're going to get
breast cancer or prostate cancer or
colon cancer.
And they could genetically engineer the
proper healthy genes, replace the bad
genes, and thus eliminate the appearance
of the disease later on. That was the
whole idea of genetic engineering.
When inborn errors of metabolism were
thought to be genetic because uh
uh people were born with these diseases
and doctors erroneously, falsely,
believed um that they were due to genes
and genetics. And one of the more common
ones is sickle cell anemia, primarily
found in the black community,
uh as sickle cell anemia. And I was
finding sickle cell anemia in deer
and in antelopes and in hummingbirds.
And how could a human genetic disease
wind up in in these animals? And so that
was my question.
And it turns out that this is not a
genetically transmitted disease. It's
called an inborn error of metabolism.
During early pregnancy, the third to the
seventh week of pregnancy,
mother's missing a mineral.
And what happens is the system that
manufactures good hemoglobin is um
not correct cuz things were missing when
it was forming.
And so you get a dysfunctional
hemoglobin. And under um not so optimal
circumstances, it will sickle.
And they'll have a crisis and certainly
can die from it.
Now, this is in the black community.
The white community, the same disease is
called thalassemia.
And they call it thalassemia because you
can't have a black gene in a white guy
or white gene in a black guy, so they
call it the same disease in two
different groups
two different names. I always thought
that was kind of interesting and began
to fill in the blanks for me
as a researcher doing all these
autopsies.
Same thing with lactose intolerance.
The lactase enzyme which is formed in
the pancreas and and the upper small
intestine, the mechanisms for forming
that enzymes are dysfunctional because
mama was missing a mineral when that was
forming
and so the equipment doesn't work after
the baby's born. But you can supplement
a
a um lactase enzyme capsule before you
go to an ice cream party, you won't be
uncomfortable and embarrass yourself and
and so forth. Totally preventable. Same
way with type 1 diabetes is not genetic.
Type 1 diabetes is an inborn error
metabolism. You're supposed to have
something like 500,000
beta cells
in an eyelid of Langerhans in which your
body makes insulin.
But when kids are born with a type 1
diabetes, they might only have
say
50 or 100
of these beta cells and they have just
enough insulin to squeak by
when um
they're 3 6 8 10 12 years old, but
they're going through puberty at you
know 10 to 12 uh they're starting to do
more physical activities and it's not
enough insulin and so they show up as a
type 1 diabetic at that point. Totally
preventable.
And certainly at this point not
reversible. Lipid storage diseases
enzymes missing. What happens is as a
person grows older they be they get
mental diseases because they're missing
the enzymes that are required to move
fats into cells and out of cells. So
what do we have left here? Well,
eugenics of course was um Francis
Galton's way of looking at it, but it's
really epigenetics. Epigenetics is as as
a science that takes the place of
genetics. And notice the subtitle in the
book Epigenetics is the death of the
genetic theory of disease transmission.
That's based on facts as you'll see here
in a moment. And Black Gene Lies,
uh Pastor Creflo Dollar from Atlanta,
Georgia in the in the uh World Changers
Church,
um because I had helped his daughter get
rid of a lifelong terrible, terrible uh
form of asthma. And he was told it was a
genetic in the black community. Uh he
was told that his daughter was not doing
very well, uh and she was not going to
make it. She wasn't responding to
uh various uh medications that normally
would help other kids
with asthma.
And so when when it was said that she
wasn't responding to medication, I knew
immediately that she wasn't absorbing
the medication, why she wasn't
responding. So we put her on a
gluten-free diet to increase her
efficiency of absorption, got her on the
90 essential nutrients, and her asthma
went away in 2 weeks because we're
giving her the raw materials and she was
able to absorb the raw materials
for her body to make all of these
hormones that are necessary to dilate
the bronchi.
Okay? We were able to support and
promote maintenance and repairs of that
system.
Well, he actually funded the first
um 100,000 copies of this book, Black
Gene Lies. He said, "Uh Doc, I want you
to get information, do the research, and
find all the diseases are said to be
genetic in the black community.
Diabetes,
heart disease, cancer, Alzheimer's
disease, um and sickle cell anemia. And
find out what's going on here. And which
diseases are genetic, which ones aren't,
what we can do to prevent the ones that
aren't, and how to cure the ones we can.
And of course, all this information is
in the book, Black Gene Lies. High blood
pressure is not genetic even in the
black population. High blood pressure is
usually due to a simple mineral
deficiency, or maybe when you have
kidney failure, um the kidneys will
release a hormone called renin, r e n i
n, to drive your blood pressure up to
try and get more
um dirty blood into the filtering units.
But it certainly is not a genetic thing,
totally preventable, and in most cases
reversible with the proper supplement
program. The death is genetic through
disease transmission.
Now,
James Watson, the director of the Cold
Springs
um genetic research laboratory in New
York and in Manhattan Island did not
coin that phrase. I coined that phrase.
Okay? But he did say that
he did say that
um
all the experiments they had done over
the last 60 years in genetics
had been irrelevant.
You can You can actually I'm quoting him
now. You can actually
sequence the genes of 150,000 people a
day who had diseases we believed were
genetically transmitted diseases.
Uh things like uh cancer, diabetes, uh
sickle cell anemia.
Uh and the reason why we weren't able to
deal with them was because they were
genetic.
Well, uh he said all that was irrelevant
because none of those diseases are
genetic.
They're either a chemical problem,
chemistry problem, biochemistry problem,
aka nutritional deficiencies. And I then
after he said that in public, I coined
the term the death of the genetic theory
of disease transmission. Remember,
there's thousands of failed medical
theories every century.
And the 20th century and the 21st
century are no different. One of the
failed theories in the 20th century and
21st century is the genetics cause
disease. It's not true.
You can see how a human embryo develops.
And if anything's missing along the way,
something's wrong with the liver. They
get a cleft palate. They get cerebral
palsy. They get spina bifida.
Uh they get Down syndrome. All
nutritional deficiencies as the embryo
develops. Totally preventable in many
cases such as cystic fibrosis and
muscular dystrophy. Even after the
baby's born, they're reversible with
supplementation because they're a
biochemical problem, not a
mechanical physical problem. One of the
places that doctors do good work is
saving preemies. 100 years ago, baby
born a pound and a half, most of them
didn't make it. Today, uh maybe 85, 90%
will make it. But those two and three
months in the incubators of special care
is not cheap. It costs 280,000 to
500,000 dollars per baby,
whether they make it or not.
And guess what?
For
600 dollars
worth of supplements
you can prevent preemies. You can
prevent all birth defects in babies.
Down syndrome is actually caused by
deficiency of a single mineral. We've
learned this in animals and we've
eliminated it in animals and of course
one out of 700 babies in America are
born with Down syndrome.
I've been able to actually prevent
and reverse
Down syndrome in an embryo. The most
famous one in 2 and 1/2 months of
pregnancy was Lauren Knievel. Evil
Knievel was a niece-in-law and she
called me and she had an amniocentesis
and she had an ultrasound both of which
said she had a very severely afflicted
Down syndrome baby. Everybody wanted to
have an abortion. She didn't want to do
that. She contacted me and asked if I
could help her.
We gave her the 90 essential nutrients,
16 minerals, 16 vitamins, 12 essential
amino acids, three fatty acids. Gave her
a little bit extra the mineral that's
missing when you have Down syndrome and
guess what?
After 9-month full-term pregnancy, her
baby was born perfectly normal. I've
done this many times since, but
obviously that's the most famous family
I've been dealing with trisomy 21 or
Down syndrome.
Cerebral palsy is a good example of a
gradient disease. Depending on
how severe the deficiencies are during
the development of the cerebellum, the
part of the brain that actually
functions to control and stimulate
proper
function of fine muscles, small muscles
and
if you're if you're born with a
cerebellum that's the size of a
tangerine, all the pieces are there,
you're going to be born normal.
But let's say you're born with a 10%
underdevelopment. You're going to walk
like Charlie Chaplin, but that might be
manageable and controllable with braces
and physical therapy. Let's say you're
25% underdeveloped of your
of your cerebellum
you're going to be flopping around with
your arms and legs. What's going to
happen here is
you will look like a classic cerebral
palsy patient.
If you're 50% underdeveloped, you're
going to be with a wheelchair for the
rest of your life because there's not
enough size and function of the
cerebellum to actually do the mechanical
things you need for muscle function.
This girl here has as much as a 90%
underdevelopment. The only thing that
she could voluntarily move herself were
her eyes. You notice the clamps holding
her head up. You notice the
the shoulder clamps and harnesses
holding her chest back in the chair. You
can see where her legs are shackled into
the chair because she we had such
terrible cerebral palsy that she is
flopping all over like a fish out of
water and she had to be restrained in
this way. This child cost $5 million a
year
to care for. Requires enormous amount of
care. Now, the interesting thing about
this child
uh when she goes through puberty
and cycles and gets married and has
kids, she can have perfectly normal kids
even if her
spouse, even if her husband has
Yes, cerebral palsy because it's not a
genetic disease. They can have normal
babies if they're getting if they're
getting all the 90 essential nutrients
prior to conception. Of course, the
cerebellum um the
part of the brain that looks like uh a
pomegranate that's been cut through in
the backside of the brain stem
there in this picture. Um this is the
part of the brain that's afflicted when
you have cerebral palsy. The smaller it
is, the more severe the cerebral palsy.
This is another one of my lawsuits
against the
FDA in federal court and basically
uh what what you see here is two little
kids, newborns, with a spina bifida.
And of course, spina bifida often times
occurs in the lumbar area can but can't
occur anywhere up and down the spine.
The one on the right also has a
um zinc deficiency. It has club feet.
Spina bifida is due to a folic acid
deficiency and I'm one of the three guys
we got together and actually sued the
FDA and that's why we have folic acid in
prenatal vitamins to prevent spina
bifida. Siamese twins are conjoined at
the pelvis. These things are all caused
by nutritional deficiencies during
pregnancy. Here is a really incomplete
Si- triplets. You see three sets of legs
there. Um the complete child also has a
club right foot, meaning his zinc
deficiency the incomplete um other
um
part of the triplets here uh are just
from the hips down. So, you see three
sets of legs, but the only complete
child is the one bigger one you see. And
all this is certainly preventable by
proper supplementation prior to
conception, all 90 essential nutrients.
Congenital deafness is caused by
deficiency of a single mineral. It's not
genetic in any way, shape, or form. And
doctors continue to form uh agencies and
programs to beg for money to find out
the gene so kids won't be born deaf.
If the mother takes the the prenatal
vitamins
preconception vitamins and minerals
prior to conception
there won't be any more children born
deaf because it's a simple mineral
deficiency, a single mineral deficiency.
Same way with uh cleft palate, cleft lip
totally caused by
a deficiency of a single mineral in the
early stages of pregnancy when the when
the flat disc of the embryo begins to
curl up into a tube, and the tube
doesn't close all at once, it closes
like a zipper. So, you can have a defect
anywhere along the underside of that
embryo, and of course, this is the last
stages of closing the embryo, or the
zipper is the mouth and the palate. The
middle and the
left-hand picture are babies that have
been egregiously impacted by thalidomide
a drug that was given to women for
morning sickness early in pregnancy, and
it interfered with zinc metabolism in
the embryos and caused the loss and
prevention of the of the production of
limbs, arms, and legs. A terrible,
terrible thing. There's a similar thing
goes on in a village in Russia where
about an average of 300 kids are born
there every year in this one village.
Half of them have the same defect on
both sides of their body. Uh 25% have
the defect in the right side, 25% have
the defect in the left side. They don't
have thalidomide, but they do have a
deficiency of that same mineral. And you
can see where the these kids were
gathered together by their photographer
to show they all had missing left
forearms. Cute little kids but they're
all missing a left forearm. Uh totally
totally preventable while the doctors
are telling them it's a genetic disease
in that community. You've all heard of
the Greek mythology of the
Cyclops, evil giant.
Um and here's a cycloptic kitten. Here's
a cycloptic lamb.
Here's a cycloptic shark. What this
tells you is when you have three
different species here having the same
problem, the same deficiency will cause
cycloptic uh anatomy in all vertebrates.
Any vertebrate that has a deficiency of
this nutrient at that particular moment
of the development of the embryo will
wind up cycloptic including humans. And
so this is why we had that um
uh Greek mythology. There were babies
born in those days with cycloptic eyes
as there is today.
Here's a human baby with Cyclops. Uh you
can see that there's no nose between the
eyes and the upper lip. The nose is
above the
uh eye. And of course this is a very
very terrible uh birth defect and most
of the time when they do a ultrasound
and they see this defect the parents
choose to
uh do an abortion. Uh many of
miscarriages uh are because these are
have low viability these babies with a
cycloptic defect. And um
they will be miscarried and so I don't
know what the percentage is but it's
very high of miscarried babies are
cycloptic babies. We look at animals
where we have control not wild animals.
We don't know the rate in wild animals
but in domestic animals we have farm
animals and pet animals is one in 16,000
have um cycloptic anatomy. In humans
when you take in the miscarriages
is one in 250. Why is that? Well that's
because we supplement animals
to prevent birth defects and human
beings are just told to eat well. Most
women will miss two periods before they
start taking prenatal vitamins. By that
time the embryo is impacted. This single
mother had one child born with 38 birth
defects. One child with 38 birth
defects. We're talking about spina
bifida, heart defects, club limbs,
cerebral palsy. And she gets
help financially from 38 different
agency that raises money to do research
on these things.
Somebody needs to go to jail here, and I
would vote for the OBGYN that managed
that pregnancy.
In 1977, I discovered the first
non-human case of cystic fibrosis in a
monkey at the Yerkes Primate Center in
Atlanta, Georgia.
And this was Emory University, Grady
Memorial Hospital. All the experts in
their laboratory head agreed that the
tissues were in fact
uh cystic fibrosis. Then I told them it
was from a non-human, a monkey, and they
were all excited to say, "Oh, we have a
laboratory animal now. We can study
cystic fibrosis."
Well, having already done by this time
all this research um with the Center for
the Biology of Natural Systems, Marlin
Perkins, Washington University, the
Saint Louis Zoo, Shaw's Botanical
Gardens, written 75 scientific papers, I
knew what to look for and began to look
for what might cause this birth defect.
Everybody said it was genetic. Well, I
found that it was due to a deficiency of
a single mineral.
Deficiency of a single mineral. Was able
to go back into the colony where this
baby monkey was being raised for NASA
for space projects.
There were 24
unrelated
monkeys, baby monkeys the same age that
still were alive, but they had the
disease. Got permission to do biopsies
of their pancreases and livers and
lungs, and sure enough they all had
cystic fibrosis. They were not related
genetically in any way, shape, or form.
Gave them the mineral that was missing
and cured them all. Wrote it up.
Asked for permission to get it
published, and I was fired from Emory
University and Yerkes Primate Center.
Said, "Wallace, you must be sniffing
glue. Everybody knows that cystic
fibrosis is
genetically transmitted." I said, "Well,
why don't you call together a committee
like you would for
um challenging a thesis for a PhD
student. Get geneticists, get experts in
cystic fibrosis, get pediatricians, and
let them challenge my evidence. Let me
bring my evidence and and respond to
them. If I can satisfy them, and they're
all agreed, then we can move forward and
get grants and save kids. But if we
can't, then go ahead and fire me." I
said no, we'd be embarrassed to tears to
call together such a committee cuz
everybody knows it is genetically
transmitted.
And this is the press release from Emory
University in March of 1978
um when they knew that we had a
non-human case of Sisyphus fibrosis.
They were very excited about it. And
they wanted to get credit for it, so
they sent out this positive news
release.
Then they fired me in another month when
I told them it wasn't genetic.
Okay, well
this is from June of 2005. June of 2005,
the International Laboratory Animal
Research Journal.
You notice it says uh serendipitous
insights involving non-human primates.
This was uh the entire journal. This
issue was uh dealing with primate
research and human diseases because at
this time the federal government had
actually defunded primate research. It's
too expensive, $1,000 a day for
primates. Use mice, it's only 10 cents a
day. If you have to use primates, go to
the Gates Foundation, get money from
them. The government's not going to pay
for it.
And so they took the top 10
serendipitous findings, the top 10
accidental findings in primate research
that benefited humanity. So well, they
said, "Look, even just by accident we
found these things." And number two out
of the top 10 for the 20th century was
the discovery of the first non-human
case of Sisyphus fibrosis, my work.
And there was a like three paragraphs in
the in that piece on the Sisyphus
fibrosis.
And the last sentence
the last portion of that sentence, they
had brackets and said, "And Emory
University refused to release the name
of the young pathologist who made the
discovery." Close brackets.
Cuz they were so embarrassed that they
had fired me.
And now they were using my work to try
and save their research programs. One of
the reasons why they didn't want it to
be a simple nutritional deficiency
disease cuz the early cost just for the
respiratory piece, just for the
respiratory piece of Sisyphus fibrosis,
and there's a digestive piece also,
and liver piece also, but for the just
the respiratory piece,
the cost for one patient is 200 almost
$260,000 a year.
Why do want to give up that kind of
income just by telling the truth?
This is why the medical system tends to
fail us is because they work for the
money as opposed to the truth. These are
some of the kids that I deal with with
cystic fibrosis, a little city marshal
in Fort Wayne, Indiana. She was supposed
to have a double lung transplant 2 and
1/2 years of age. Her parents didn't
have insurance, didn't have money, and
so they came to me and we put her on the
program.
And here she is 6 and 1/2 years later
winning a dance contest.
And of course she's perfectly normal at
this time and she'll be able to have
normal babies and no problem. Now, an
opportunity came along in 1989 for me to
go to Keshan province, China. I went to
Keshan province, China to do autopsies
on kids that died of Keshan disease,
which is a deficiency of a single
mineral. Now, the same mineral
is the same deficiency that causes
cystic fibrosis.
Now, that's not unusual. People say,
"Well, you must be infatuated with that
mineral." No.
Calcium deficiency can result in 147
different diseases.
Zinc deficiency is a big, big cause of
many different birth defects.
And so,
this mineral deficiency, selenium, is no
different. There's probably 25 different
diseases caused by
selenium deficiency.
Well, Keshan disease, as it's called, is
named after the province in China where
it occurs so frequently because there's
little or no of of this mineral,
selenium, in the soil there.
Plants that they grow, corn and wheat,
don't require selenium.
And when these poor farm kids eat these
grains, they get plenty of calories,
maybe a little protein, but they don't
get any of those minerals. And thousands
of them die every month. There's over
300 million people in that one state.
There's over 300 million people in those
provinces. So, when a couple of thousand
kids die every month, it's a serious
problem, obviously,
but it's not like it's an epidemic going
through and killing millions and so per
month. And so, this is one of those
things where
uh they just sort of learned to live
with it. They would supplement these
kids with selenium and they saved many
of them by doing that. So, I went there
and I said, "If I'm correct and cystic
fibrosis is by congenital sleem
deficiency, by deficiency of sleem
during pregnancy,
then some of these kids in China and
Keshan province are going to have
Rebosis. And I took that thought to a
people who are geneticists and people
who were experts in in Rebosis,
and they laughed at me again. They said,
"Well, now we know why you got fired.
You're really dumb."
Because Chinese kids don't get
Rebosis. I said, "Really?
I bought topsies oriental kids and black
kids that had Rebosis.
And I went to China.
1,700 autopsies.
1,700 autopsies in this program.
And I was hoping for one or three or
five or something like that kids with
Rebosis. Well, it turns out that
35% 595 of them had Rebosis.
Out of the 1,700.
It was unimpeachable evidence. The
slides are still there in the
universities where the work was done.
It can be tracked. We can redo the study
again. We'll have the same result. I
guarantee that.
Sent copies of this published in
English,
published in Chinese, in peer-reviewed
refereed scientific journals. And guess
what?
Sent them to the Rebosis
Foundation. Never had a response.
They should have their non-profit status
taken away from them. Because every
child that's born with Rebosis or
dies of Rebosis is on their head.
Somebody needs to go to jail. Okay?
Well, I got a three for when I did those
1,700 autopsies because they also found
out the cause for and a cure for
muscular dystrophy.
Worked on that for years. Actually,
I worked with
the Amish communities which have a very
high rate of muscular dystrophy. And
guess what? We're able to support,
promote, manage, repair, reverse
muscular dystrophy. Even their own
doctors said it was reversed.
Gave Jerry Lewis
from the Muscular Dystrophy Foundation
copies of many of these kids' reports
and their their records
showing even their doctors said they had
had their muscular muscular reversed.
He took it to the Muscular Dystrophy
Foundation and they fired Jerry Lewis
for insisting that they look at this
seriously.
They fired Jerry Lewis. Again, I believe
they should have their
their um tax-exempt status taken away
from them cuz every time a kid is born
with muscular dystrophy or dies from it,
it's on their heads. Somebody needs to
go to jail.
Cardiovascular disease, we've already
talked about this briefly. A congestive
heart failure, deficiency of a single
vitamin. Cardiomyopathy, heart disease.
Keshan disease is a deficiency of a
single mineral. Coronary artery disease
is caused by inflammation, eating fried
foods, processed meats, oils, microwave
popcorn, all that kind of stuff.
And then coronary thrombosis is caused
by an omega-3 essential fatty acid
deficiency. None of these cardiovascular
diseases
is caused by what? Cholesterol or
saturated fat.
It was a sales campaign to sell Crisco.
Remember, Procter & Gamble
gave the American Heart Association,
brokered by Ancel Keys,
$1.7 million to endorse Crisco and
demonize cholesterol. Records show now
that the
heart age of of most
people in the industrialized world,
including America,
are older than their chronological age.
In men, it's 7.8 years older. In women,
5.6 years older. That's because of the
eating of trans fats and heterocyclic
amines, which cause particular
inflammation in the in the coronary
arteries and cause heart disease.
And this just shows you a map what part
of the continental United States and the
islands of Hawaii and Alaska have the
highest rates of um heart ages that are
far older than their chronological age.
Here's one of the bad boys when it comes
to cardiovascular disease, microwave
popcorn. We're seeing more and more kids
uh we're talking about eight,
10-year-olds, 3-year-olds, 2-year-olds
dying of heart disease,
coronary artery disease, because what?
Oh,
they're being baby sat with
microwave popcorn. You know, the parents
can't afford babysitters, so they give
them a bag of microwave popcorn and let
them watch TV or put on a a giggly
cartoon movie while they're doing work
in the kitchen,
and uh
these kids are dead by the time they're
in their teens and early 20s. Microwave
popcorn contributes to 50,000 heart
attacks a year, 20,000 deaths, front
page story in the USA today. Now, the
new Crisco, of course, again demonized
by the American Heart Association
exchanged for 1.7 million dollars. Um
Procter & Gamble always trying to expand
their market. And what they wanted to do
was have you deep fry your Thanksgiving
turkey in Crisco instead of roasting it
like we've done traditionally since uh
the days of the revolution. The new
Crisco, made to help take the fat worry
out of good eating. Well, who put the
fat worry into it? The American Heart
Association by demonizing cholesterol
and saturated fat. And of course, all
this story came from two full pages of
the New York Times.
And basically, we're talking about
saturated fat does not cause heart
disease.
Okay? And of course, this goes back to
Dr. Ancel Keys again. He was uh
through his force of will. I mean, this
guy was one of these bombastic guys. He
could pound on the podium and yell and
scream, and people believed him cuz he
was so forceful, and uh he drove the use
of Crisco rather than milk and cream and
um butter and eggs and lard. Now, in
addition
to demonizing cholesterol and saturated
fat, they actually looked at making it
sexier to use Crisco. And so, they
looked at the
uh Isle of Crete and came up with a
Mediterranean diet. In fact, the
Mediterranean diet was a fraud. It was a
sales campaign to sell Crisco. There's
no evidence to back up any of the claims
for the Mediterranean diet.
Fried foods, trans fats
cause stroke. They contribute to the
inflammation of arteries
um that cause stroke. If you're
deficient omega-3s and you're eating a
lot of fried foods, you're going to get
a stroke. If even if you're 2 years old,
even if you're 6 months old.
Keshan Province in the red here,
selenium-depleted red area. Now,
you've all heard of SIDS, sudden infant
death syndrome. And of course, another
failed theory was doctors said that SIDS
was caused by the baby sleeping on their
back.
What a dumb theory that was.
They didn't use the special stains to
see if
the SIDS was caused by heart disease. In
fact, these kids that died of SIDS when
they're 2 months old, 2 weeks old, was
caused by a deficiency of selenium. It
was Keshan's disease. I did the special
stains because I'm a a pathologist that
looks at those details.
And so, we actually sued the FDA for
many years trying to get selenium into
prenatal formulas and also into
infant formulas after the baby's born.
And we had a big fight. And they didn't
like the idea that this might deal with
genetic diseases like cystic fibrosis
and muscular dystrophy. So, when we
talked about SIDS,
um they signed off on that one. They
signed off on that one. Let us put it in
infant formulas. In fact, it's required.
Selenium is now required in infant
formulas to deal with SIDS.
But, through the back door, we're also
going to eliminate muscular dystrophy
and cystic fibrosis because it'll also
deal with that. So,
uh we had to do a little surreptitious
things there and go through the back
door to get a threefer.
And these are the sort of kids that
would die from Keshan disease from a
selenium deficiency cuz they lived
entirely on wheat and corn in a place
that had little or no selenium in the
soil.
Dr. Fred Kern, professor of medicine at
the University of Colorado,
was uh training a bunch of newly
graduated medical doctors on how to
examine
seniors. And he found this chart of an
88-year-old guy. He said, "Come on,
let's go examine this guy." Goes in the
examining room and he looks at him.
He says, "Is this you?" He points at the
chart. Says, "Is this you?" "Yeah." He
says, "The chart here says you're 88
years old. You don't look that old." He
says, "Yeah, people say I look like I'm
50."
He says, "What do you attribute your
youthful looks to and you're 88 years
old?"
And he said,
"I eat 25 eggs a day.
I've been doing it for 17 years. I'm
going to do it for another 100 years."
Well, of course, this is not what Dr.
Kern was looking for in front of these
students. And I I didn't say it in the
article, but I guarantee he sat down,
he's fanning himself with his clipboard.
Said, "Okay, sir.
Why are you eating 25 eggs a day?" And
the guy stands up, throws his chest out,
throws his shoulders back, and said,
"Because it makes me more studly." Now,
you think about that.
When you look at testosterone, estrogen,
progesterone, adrenal hormones, they're
all steroid hormones, and they're 95% by
weight cholesterol.
They're 95% by weight cholesterol.
You want a cholesterol-restricted diet,
and you're taking statin drugs to lower
your cholesterol.
There's nobody home anymore. You get
erectile dysfunction, low T. Women go
into uh menopause when they're 35 years
old and start getting hot flashes and
night sweats, and they stop cycling when
they're 35, 40 years old cuz they're not
making enough hormones.
You get adrenal exhaustion. But, even
more importantly than all that,
we had a new disease, a new big boy
disease, called Alzheimer's disease. 45
years ago, Alzheimer's disease didn't
exist even by another name. Today, it's
the number four killer of adults over
the age of 65. It's driven. It's a
physician-caused disease.
75% of the human brain weight is the
white matter of the brain, the myelin.
It's called myelin. It's the insulation
material of the brain. And this myelin
that makes up 75% of your brain weight
is 100% cholesterol.
So, you want a cholesterol-restricted
diet,
no more
cholesterol in your blood or very little
because you're getting it down to like
100 uh with statin drugs, you're going
to get Alzheimer's disease. So,
Alzheimer's uh Alzheimer's disease is a
a um preventable disease. It's a
reversible disease. And um this is the
entire story
of saturated fat and cholesterol in Time
magazine. When you look at Ancel Keys on
the left part of your screen, and Ancel
Keys here, um I mean, he even looks like
a Nazi. He was um actually put on the
cover of Time magazine as the hero who
saved American cardiovascular um system
by identifying cholesterol and saturated
fat as the evil ones. He was the one to
demonize them. Cholesterol on the front
page of Time magazine.
And this is the sort of way this is the
method they used to demonize
cholesterol.
On your right hands part of your screen,
Time magazine eat butter. Big scoop of
butter on the cover.
And this is a
uh article obviously cover story five
pages talks about the um story with
Ansel Keys and how he um got Procter &
Gamble to endorse a
diesel engine submarine lubricant for
cooking as opposed to
butter, cream, lard, and eggs.
And this uh one uh on the right-hand
side, Time magazine eat butter. This is
from June 23rd, 2014. Says scientist
labeled fat saturated fat the enemy and
why they were wrong. You need to read
that one and you'll realize how badly
you've been defrauded by the medical
system and the pharmaceutical industry.
The individuals on Earth, the culture on
Earth that has the fewest cardiovascular
events are the Inuit Eskimos above the
Arctic Circle. No less than a dozen
times a year there's articles printed in
scientific journals on these peoples.
And they're kind of unique. They just
don't get cardiovascular disease. And
yet 90% of their traditional diet above
the Arctic Circle is red meat and fat.
They eat nothing but whale meat and
whale blubber, walrus meat and walrus
blubber, seal meat and seal blubber,
bear meat and bear fat. They don't eat
vegetables or fruit. They don't eat nuts
and grain. Their cholesterols run 350 to
500.
They don't get cardiovascular disease
until they come down into the lower 48
and eat like us.
Salt is not bad. Salt has two essential
nutrients and it's sodium and chloride.
Required for all kinds of chemical
reactions inside cells.
Can't live without sodium and chloride.
And of course um chlorine is also
required to make stomach acid to keep
your stomach sterile, to help pepsin the
enzyme digest uh proteins, amino acids,
and help the Castle's intrinsic factor
to absorb B12. Also to absorb most
minerals you're going to require
uh stomach acid. You're going to get
reflux if you don't have enough stomach
acid to keep your stomach sterile
because yeast and bacteria will grow in
there.
And so you need stomach acid to keep
your stomach sterile. Anybody who tells
you to restrict your salt because of
high blood pressure should be put in
jail. Somebody needs to go to jail here.
1982, salt the new villain. 2014, salt
doesn't cause high blood pressure.
This shows you death rates
okay, from heart disease.
And then of course, in February of 2012,
the FDA sent an urgent stop email to all
licensed medical doctors in America.
It says stop writing prescription for
statin drugs, Lipitor, Zocor, Mevacor,
Lovastatin, these kinds of things.
And they listed them
on that email. Stop writing
prescriptions for these drugs. Stop
telling your patients to get on
cholesterol-restricted diets. Because if
you continue to do this, you're going to
increase the risk of type 2 diabetes by
52%
and Alzheimer's disease by 100%. 4
months later, Science News, June of
2012,
good cholesterol not so beneficial. Wait
a minute, your doctor says it's
everything.
Of course, they say
it's not beneficial.
And then they went on to say that higher
HDL, high-density lipoprotein, the good
cholesterol, high good cholesterol
levels don't reduce the rate of heart
disease or heart attacks. Why is that?
Because no heart disease is caused by
cholesterol or saturated fat.
Remember, congestive heart failure is
caused by deficiency of single vitamin.
Cardiomyopathy heart disease caused by
deficiency of single mineral.
Coronary artery disease is caused by
inflammation.
And thrombotic heart disease, coronary
thrombosis, blood clot in the coronary
artery or brain artery, is caused not by
cholesterol or saturated fat, but
an omega-3 essential fatty acid
deficiency. Margarine
is the worst type of fat for the heart.
And this includes the margarine that's
in between the chocolate cookies and
Oreo cookies.
And here's the front cover story, FDA
to trim trans fats out of food. And I
thought they were too lenient on the
people who had trans fats in their foods
they manufactured. They gave them 3
months to do it, and that's 90 days.
Uh when you have so many thousands of
people dying from this, and our young
kids dying from this, somebody needs to
go to jail.
Let's look at athletes real quickly.
Exercise is thought to be a very, very
good thing. It can be, if done properly.
But let's look at professional athletes,
look at athletes, and let's look at
their average lifespan. Let's look at
how long they live. Jim Fix, the darling
of the medical world, because he said
you don't have to supplement, all you
have to do is um run and you keep your
arteries clean. He died at 52 while he
was running.
His protege, his top student, Brian
Maxwell from Canada, died at age 51
while running. He had 12 gold medals in
long-distance running, three of which
were in the Olympics.